what's going on man different by the way
you look thinner and you've cut your
hair there's something very different
about your face it's like it maybe it's
just dinner it's just dinner I was like
25 pounds look yeah thanks man Morgan I
don't know if Jim fully grasped the dock
because his takeaway was that he agreed
with you he said in that fast food is
good because chickens are spoiled I
would know I was saying that there was a
show the picture you don't have the
picture is out of context you watch that
film you're like I I can't I can't help
but think that holy chicken make some
delicious chicken sandwiches that's my
thing you see the film that's what's
great about holy chicken that your your
fast-food establishment is the stamped
on grill marks that's right look you
have a grill Stamper so you can deep-fry
something and just stamp it there's
grill much we paint we paint grill them
with flavor char we trademarked our own
our own paint grill marks flavor right
right yeah you started this from you
said I want to start a chicken
restaurant from scratch and see what the
process is to build it up correct so we
wanted to show you like the first film
kind of shows you from a consumer
perspective what goes into you know us
eating the choices we make and then so I
said well let's do a film from the
corporate side where I'm going to open
my own fast-food restaurant and show you
that goes what everything that goes into
that and I'm gonna show you how me as
like CEO gets you to buy what I want you
to eat how do i market to you how do I
sell you what you want the poor and
actually make money on it the poor
people that are like oh this is great
everything's green and it's and it's
natural organic look at all these words
on the wall and it's like every trap
that gets fully explained in the film
that's right I just watch people walk
into Morgan's restaurant and they're
like yeah I'd like I'd like to crispy
grilled sandwich that's right crispy and
grill grill it's fantastic and they're
going like is it fried and they go we
don't use that word we say crisp we
don't use the f-word in whole chicken we
say crispy and servers like always
crispy chicken causes cancer there was a
new study that just like literally does
everything cause cancer I really think
so I try to eat chicken to be healthier
wait to hear about I mean you watch this
thing wait you hear about the big
chicken industry oh my god
everybody's heard a big tobacco big
chicken is huge yeah so chicken in the
United States is
controlled by five companies they
controlled 97% of the chicken that you
eat the chicken that's grown the chicken
that's sold it's cooked it's Perdue it's
Tyson its Anderson its pilgrims pilgrims
pride and these guys not only control
the market but they control the farmers
themselves I mean I'm in the studio with
two of our chicken farmers who who
raised our chickens Zach Buttram a raise
the chickens and his dad Jonathan who's
one of our advisors who like these guys
have been blackballed from the industry
because they speak out against big
chicken they talk about what's happening
so now none of these companies will work
with them they kind of you know slag
them in the press and the media it's
crazy
is it hard till I get just help I just
want chicken that like the the things
you have no idea how to just get I just
want to lose a decent life over the head
to put make me a sandwich a little
chicken pillows just put over their face
and go one chicken dies three days later
the chickens wife dies clucking no no
remembrance of where they are I feel
like that's new tagline for holy chicken
it's the notebook but for chicken so
what do you eat now you know everything
about food that's awfully what can you
comfortably eat I do
I just breathe I just breathe piece of
rice that's like I eat a lot of chicken
I eat lunch chicken I eat a lot of fish
I say things like I still love a steak
but I don't need a lot of red meat they
are like right once or twice a month
we'll have a steak I took these guys to
Peter lubbers when they were in town
I've never eaten they're here it's great
and see how choice things where it's
like they're either state places I like
better than here on Lugar's but it's the
experience going to Peter lubbers you
get the chicken from these guys now they
we're did not get our chicken we get
their chickens in the film from Jonathan
Wright I praise them and so moving
forwards we didn't have time we're doing
a pop up in New York City opens on
Wednesday is the rest of restaurant
opens in New York City for everybody to
come down check out 18 West 23rd Street
so so when you're sitting there right
and you're watching you know that this
thing is happening within the next few
weeks and you're watching the world
explode over popeyes chicken sandwiches
are you going oh my god like this
couldn't be better promotion is like
this sounds like a great time to bring
the grilled crispy chicken sandwich
right in the middle of the right
middle of a witch war here's the best
part Morgan's gonna realize how much
money he can make in a restaurant and
then the documentary he's gonna be like
[ __ ] this and you're gonna be a
full-time chicken restaurant owner he's
gonna call these poor gentlemen over
here ago and like I know that like
you're doing it the right way it's much
more affordable to get it from people
like a big juicy chicken shutting the
[ __ ] up are like how is it delicious man
part of it is because the chicken breast
it's like it's like a foot tall it's
like this thick like it big enough that
you could never have that breast on a
chicken you are gonna love the holy
chicken gross this is what I'm not
telling you this is the greatest chicken
sandwich you ever gonna have in your
life right and is it is the greatest
chicken sandwich you are ever going to
be good for you right it's of course
good for you we tell you that right so
it must be good for you what is organic
me cuz I'm a dope I actually look at
that goal alright what's something like
yeah well organic organic hopefully
means that they are free-range which
ultimately as you learn in the film
doesn't really mean anything around a
field so much extra money in the
supermarket
you're like the free-range organic grown
chicken and I'm like oh they just saw me
coming yeah you know what they do they
open the door window and so because
ultimately and we show you this in the
film where I'm raising the chickens in
the film you know supersize me - holy
chicken which will be everywhere on
demand starting this Friday you can see
it anywhere it's great so the the fin
the film I talked to you about what is
what goes into labeling of these birds
or what would it take for me to range
raise free-range birds and so I start
doing research I call the USDA there's
like no there's no guidelines there's no
parameters how much space you have to
give them so I literally open up a door
and we put a cage myself in zach-bots
room we put this tiny little cages
probably five feet by five feet
sent to the USDA gets approved
free-range and and to be classified as
free-range than chicken never even has
to go outside like they just have to
have access to outside it's their choice
it's their choice there's a kind of a
lecture they want to see a tree
you could have gone those chickens could
have gone outside they chose to stay
otherwise that's a forced range chicken
and make them go outside I think we've
got a new term for string works really
good we're putting all treadmills making
them go outside it's actually even
better than free-range I was watching
the movie and like you're gone from like
restaurant to rescuing what's good for
the chickens we're doing what's good for
them so it's all strange it's like when
you take an obese person and you make
them exercise because it's like you're
gonna die you got to do something for
yourself
I was the premise of holy chicken the
restaurant is that he's taking the guts
of old fast-food restaurants and turning
them into something right yeah tell you
the truth about the business the whole
way right yeah but with a smile
that's right okay in a very nice way but
you guys start going to like every
different restaurant and I'm like well
yeah everybody knows this is bad for you
then you show up to a Chipotle and I'm
like off chicken it's awful
yeah well it's and it's also just not
that it's the calorie count interpolate
that's what you don't realize you don't
realize when you're getting one of those
big breeders are the bowls like sudden
you've just eaten like 12 1500 calories
for lunch you know it's like these I
mean that was the one that I was
literally Chipotle was like no no no no
I'm gonna do good today
today's Chipotle yeah and it's like
that's not that's a well isn't this
problem with all of it is it's such this
food system where the food comes from
almost all of it comes from the same bad
five chicken farm well the thing is like
again is there better than other chicken
of course there is there's always
chicken that's better than other chicken
but ultimately what does that mean
that's what you show you in the film
that just because it says better doesn't
mean it's ultimately raised better that
it has that much better of a life I mean
it's hard like free-roaming is what you
want to see on out on a roaming free
roaming which like and those chickens
are so expensive right so those are ones
that actually are out running around
they're like eating bugs they're getting
seen not free-range free roaming free
roaming you actually got to catch them
which makes you work for it you can't
just shove them in a in a steel
Tupperware but those chickens will cost
you know sometimes you know 14 14 bucks
a pound you know you're getting a whole
chicken cost you $30 you know it's
insane like what you realize is we show
you over this movie is that to have that
level of chicken the demand
one isn't there to drive down costs
right and two that's just there's not an
industry in place to push that into a
place that makes it affordable for
people like you does every store sell it
free roaming chicken no they don't
because it's not cost-effective but I'm
sure you like Whole Foods place like
that rich people stores yeah yeah like
Fresh Direct in New York I'm sure they
deliver them but most people most people
will carry you know the free-range those
types of birds all natural hormone free
oh good are they all these thing well
cuz the eih are not allowed to put
hormones and chickens anyway and we're
but you can still say yeah years ago
they were allowed to do that put it in
their feed but now now they're not
allowed to do it at all Jonathan Buttram
can talk to this Jonathan talk to us
about hormones and chickens yeah what is
he in Farmer chicken farmer Jonathan but
room chickens have been had hormones in
them for years now then these large
factory farms big big guys lobby
Congress and get the names of hormones
change so they're healthy in there's no
change the name of the hormones it's not
a hormone reclassify Oh kind of
underhanded stuff like dropshipping
antibiotics from Canada and making the
farmer run them through these water
systems so they're not connected with it
and stuff like this this still gets by
with us now so why did you decide Jesus
to actually do it the right way
and keep doing it the right way Lee why
at no point did you go this is
ridiculous like I gotta just the system
is the system I can't beat it I just got
to do it I gotta go joined Purdue and
just do this the way people do it it's
in my blood when God made us farmers he
made us to take care of the animals and
I step back and look at it that's wrong
I don't want my grandkids eating this
nasty stuff I want to eat and get
free-range chickens in and that's that's
what it's all about is help health wise
and all that so are you worried that
your shine it's gonna like you know wait
for you to be too old to do anything
about it they go like okay dad's out of
the picture we can go let's go hey
Purdue we're ready to go I mean that's a
good thing Razak to talk to because like
Jonathan's father was chicken farmer
Jonathan che guevara Zack who's now a
third-generation chicken farmer who
raised our birds for holy chicken like
he's a great person to talk
- about what is the what the industries
like right now especially for a young
farmer like easy young farmer he's got
young kids like he can talk about like
how things have changed yeah well so
because of dad trying to speak out and
try to do the right thing he raised me
the same way like no matter what I gotta
go what I knows right right I got
completely blackballed just because of
his father name name is toxic in big
chicken I couldn't even get a contract
I had five million dollars pre-approved
from several banks to start me an eight
house super farm with all big houses and
everything what's an eighth house super
farm or eight chicken houses the new
houses that are 66 foot wide by 600 foot
long their mega houses how many can you
fit in there us 49,000 in each morning
on the size of chicken and pop I still
ran out of sandwiches
that's incredible but so like our
farming blood line guy ended because he
spoke out and they just completely
discriminated against me said no you
might as well go with stable to coming
here with I'm like I have a contract
with anybody right Who am I supposed to
grow chickens for if I can't go for one
of y'all well you're just in a bad area
a bad area like I'm in the middle of the
chicken Belt in Alabama how is there
anywhere a bad area right here right and
now there's houses sitting on the land
that we owned at the time but it was a
bad area for a bad area when you were
there yeah you shold off the lane yes
and they're like oh this is great place
to put some chicken houses that I see a
hundred thousand chickens if you if you
if you can fit 49 or 50 thousand in each
house new date house that's a lot so we
had a 12 house farm that's an empty now
Wow
they were built in 1986 I grew up in
those chicken houses my whole entire
life spent with my dad on that farm and
I got the chance to go start working on
that after I got out of college and
continue to try to farm on it and then
he spoke out
we got nailed by everybody it's done and
just you know I'm piss-poor I love all
across the country their farming is just
like these guys who are getting
blackballed by the industry you're
getting pushed out of the business I
mean it's it's terrible what's happening
I mean I know there's five companies but
it feels like this is why monopoly laws
are in place yeah yeah this doesn't
happen but it's but it's exactly why it
still happens right
yeah I mean it's awful one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM Avenue